d'accueil maintenant mclain ward
mesdames messieurs
ça va il ya du beau monde ce soir
alors marc c'est vrai que pendant le
tournage du film de ravalec qui
s'appelle cantique de la racaille on
vous appelez marque ouille ça commence
fort le mec
mais tout le monde fini par m'appeler
marcoule sur ce tournoi vous avez le
marc quinn de majorque où il salue marco
et quand il était plus jeune alors on
l'appeler marco les grandes feuilles
mais là maintenant mais la tête a grossi
les oreilles en herbe plus petit
finalement aller quand même a toujours
des bonnes petites oreilles il ya un
truc incroyable c'est qu'à la même
époque de marcolet les grandes feuilles
détient un peu bouboule main vous
appelez gras double cd par khouya marc
laboulle a jamais eu d sur donc bien
alors aujourd'hui ça va vous n'avez plus
de complexes sur votre physique
marc lavoine ou simplement vous dites
mon physique je le trouve plutôt dur
genre nazis couper au couteau alors ça
quand même
c'est terrible ça parce que vous êtes
beaux anges non mais vous pensez vous
ressemblez une statue d'arnaud breaker
non non mais ça si c'est un nom on
attache moi on avait dix alors parfois
qu'il m'avait vu wayne à un tableau de
ce monsieur c'est le peintre du
troisième reich
c'est le sculpteur du 3ème âge donc
c'est sûr que ça ça fait plaisir ça
envoie sur une axiologie remets ta
génération comme attaché de presse tu
sois aussi d'ailleurs il a mis en
confiance tout de suite a été un peu
trop cultivé ac fera qu'en fait je te
prête ça fait plaisir sur semble à une
sculpture dano breaker alors votre père
voulait jazzman il a fini au tri postal
à vaugirard fait pas toujours ce qu'on
veut dans la vie et votre mère est
pianiste est venu dactylo fait pas loin
de ces messages avaient pensé c'est pas
loin mais arrête avec ses seins parce
que je m'attends à le mener jusqu'à j'ai
fait ça je me suis fait la matière parce
que depuis excuse moi mais je comprends
mais qu'elle le fait exprès en tous les
cas on peut dire marc lavoine que vous
avez assouvir les ambitions culturelles
d'euros par an mais d'une certaine façon
vous allez vous avez fait vous
ce que eux rêvé de faire une certaine
façon non c'est vrai alors vous avez été
élevé dans une culture politique qui a
complètement disparu effectivement
c'était le culte de malcolm x le culte
de la révolution des oeillets au
portugal
cohn bendit votre père vit toujours il
est monté sur le lion de belfort sa
salle en salle fasciné c'est moi qui
suis possible
ben c'est vrai vous avez dans ce monde
là et quand vous étiez petit vous croyez
que tous les communistes étaient
gentilles et je crois que tout le monde
était commune et surtout alors vous êtes
échapper tout ça en partant les
week-ends en mobylette avec des copains
pour tourner en super-8 des spectacles
en plein air donc voilà il y avait un
truc aussi c'est que vous vous êtes
croyants et votre père l'était pas oui
mon laisser un peu le choix
comment croyant ça m'intéresse comment
on peut être croyant quand on vit dans
un univers où dieu n'existe pas ayons vu
quand j'ai plus conscience de la mort
ouais là je me suis dit on est
voilà on est peu de chose cette croyance
budget ni un canton n'a rien du tout ni
papa ni maman plus rien excepté un demi
frère
je crois que c'est évident qu'on pense
que marie josèphe lamari dieu tout ça
c'est une famille je vends devenir le
prochain ca du mont sainte vierge
jésus joseph c'est les parents puis j'ai
vite compris que c'était de la tarte
alors bon vous finalement on en venait
d'un milieu comme on l'a dit communiste
1 avec ce que ça d'humaniste bien
entendu puisque sa terrible avec
budapest 156 ou prague etc et vous
épousez la dernière descendante des rois
de pologne qu'est ce qu'il a dit votre
père mario ça va avec sarah annonce va
bien j'ai vue à poil devant là il ya pas
longtemps
oui vous avez une photo de vacances et
c'est bien ravie je pense que
convaincant s'en soit poil sur une plage
puis tout le monde le wasquehal gilles
bannier photo de face
si vous les avez ils les ont alors bon
on va terminer là dessus mais c'est
assez assez grave
ce que je vais vous dire là en 97 dans
le journal l'alsace
vous avez déclaré marc lavoine je suis
un mauvais coup bas cherry montré moins
tu m as avec génie elle s'est aggravée
ces voir barry tu lis dans les lignes de
l'amour bah oui un très bon et le riz le
hic
l'outil mon team ou dans les jeux vendus
ni aucun doute oui les mauvais coups je
suis comme les interviews dont
l'interview parce qu'on sait c'est toi
qui l'a dit nous des gens ont dit que
c'était moi c'est lui qui l'avait dit
bien alors votre carrière
au départ vous faites des études
d'imprimerie vous faites sincérité et
d'imprimerie vous apprenez l'imprimerie
parce que d'abord vous habitez avis où
il ya des plans l'imprimerie avis ou non
c'est pda prévu et ça pousse l'honneur
de jouer tout court je vais tout tenter
un dribble entre le col et je l'aimé
sous efficiency en bleu c'est très bien
d'être en bleu
bah oui c'est bien moi était bien c'est
là où on voit justement c'est vrai que
les gens font la différence
vous êtes dans des moments comme ça où
on a du cambouis ou l'un c'est vraiment
j'étais en blanc moi je tends peintres
en bâtiment pour draguer ben c'est pas
pareil
et puis alors bon vous êtes coursier
placer à l'olympia là c'est miraculeux
un jour patricia coquatrix vous présente
florence aboulker qui vous présente son
fils fabrice aboulker et puis voilà et
puis c'est parti didier
robbie deans
je donne tout aussi déserté tous les
animaux
les yeux oui
elle a le regard qui tue
hier m je sais vous tuer
m
partout
oui
cb
commente ce qu'ils sont
et
les
oh
ici
la nuit
je
fuyez le premier single extrait de cet
album qui n'a pas de titre est le
deuxième single c'est ça
et
ce sont
ces jeunes
je suis
j'ai tout oublié ma flamme
c'est leurs études ça c'est un duo avec
cristina marocco qui est une chanteuse
italienne un sicilienne puis alors il ya
sur l'album en question il ya trois
autres duos avec françoise hardy avec
claire keim avec souad massi cessé il ya
eu catherine ringer il ya eu véronique
sanson princess erika
c'est quoi cette histoire de faire des
duos c'est parce qu au théâtre quand on
est au théâtre on est toujours avec des
partenaires et c'est vrai que quand on
chante ça manque fallait duo surtout
avec des femmes aussi incroyable que
véronique sanson image et de sa non
d'ailleurs
pour claire keim c'est en voyant clair
dans votre émission chantier que l on la
connaissait que l'arrondi net on le
prend avec et où les occasions non et
moi je cherchais quelqu'un pour la
chanson je ne veux qu'elle elle m'a dit
lui bref les clercs à l'achat les
phallus émissions et elle nous a dit
elle a chanté chaire d'histoire était
incroyable et donc du coup ça s'est fait
un peu à celle où thierry l'écouté voilà
je suis très content